hello everyone again and I say again as
I already made this video and uploaded
some hour and half ago but similarly
like I think we could or ten days ago my
video for I mean image you got stuck and
you could only hear me but you couldn't
see anything I have no idea why this
happens again might be an update in the
camera drivers or something but I
this time I decided to to repeat the
video as it's really an insane game I
would hate for you to miss it so let's
just check out we have a nice photo
there we have it it's not actually a
photo it's just a still image from the
live feed but there you have it cross
and vs. moment you're off and before we
check out the game I would just like to
mention that my media is the last person
to beat Magnus Carlsen in classical time
control it happened last year in the
bilges festival so will be interesting
to see what calls and chooses to play
against mommy they are here and Ken
Mahmud yarv again and course and streak
which I believe is now over 70 games
undefeated so mom Dara opens with whitey
plays Knight to f3 we have the ready
story about that we have Knight to f6 by
moment they are of c-4 with g6 preparing
to fianchetto the dark square Bishop
Knight to c3 and now d5 a nice strike in
the center we have C captures Knight
captures and here there are a couple of
moves I mean more than a couple of moves
you could play Queen a4 is the main line
here they'll ever check you could play F
or go into a sort of a room feel like
structure but here Carlsen goes h4
inspired by some you know all the alpha
zeros game-changing advices you want to
start attacking from the beginning as a
black already gave you a target so here
with Knight captures and c3b captures
and Bishop to g7 just continuing
development normally and h5 here course
and of course it does not want to
capture on g6 as long as this rookie
still on h8 so cross and will wait for
for black to castle and this isn't a new
position or anything it has been played
before c5 is the main move here and
mommy replace it with rook to be won by
cousin hindering the development of the
light square bishop here and here well
you could try something like knight c6
or some other move that were played
before b6 is a new move and already from
move eight we have
lately new game so very exciting with
efore by Carson and now comes castles by
Mamedov and now that mob er castled
coughs cousin is ready to capture on g6
with H captures H captures and now d4
just developing in the center and oh
it's like in the groom field you want to
fight for the d4 square and here mama
deer has to decide where he wants to go
Bishop g4 or brusha brusha b7 as he
already played b6 he decided to develop
his bishop this way and now Knight to g5
really an interesting idea across and
already has some checkmating plans and
he wants to go Queen g4 Queen h4 deliver
checkmate on h7 and mom you have
captured some d4 he allows this and now
cousin goes Queen to g4 there was some
talk that Bishop to c4 was already
giving whites in the winning advantage
but it's without actually preparing this
it's really hard to see there are some
ideas like Queen the c7 Kasparov
mentioned that during the interview that
you have Queen to b3 just powering up
the attack against the f7 square and
then you can also go back up to a3 and
it will supposedly be just overwhelming
for like to hold this but cousin plays
Queen to g4 which is interesting it
means that even though he chose such a
wild line he did not prepare it at home
he just you know plays it by instinct so
the idea is Queen h4 followed by Queen -
h7 mate with Knight to d7 preparing
Knight to f6 from f6 the knight will
cover the h7 square although there is
another way you could defend queen c8
it's a more adventurous way to defend
and then after Queen h4 just rook c8 you
invite Quint h7 as your king will be
safe on FA but like I said maybe a bit
too adventurous for mama D off he was
Quint after Queen to g4 he goes Knight
to d7
we have Queen to h3 not Queen to h4 some
of you may already have heard this in
the previous video I don't know why
Queen to h3 is better than Queen to h4
to me Queen to h4 seems like a more
natural move still keeping an eye on
this pawn here again threatening
checkmate so it's the same but from here
I don't know why Queen to h3 is better
if any of you have some sort of an idea
of course to do share we have Knight to
f6 you wanna defend the h7 Square and
now a cousin has to decide whether he
wants to
97 which is very nice as you're
threatening to capture the night we'll
check and deliver mate on h7 so black
would have to go night h5 you would win
the exchange here but black would have
very nice compensation for the exchange
the strong disrepair in the night and
age 5 prevents white from doing any
attacks the bishop just excellent
defending the peace and the constant
skin still stuck on e1 black black is to
be preferred here so after Knight to f6
Magnus continues with his caveman
approach or some called the Barbarian
approach as you just keep on attacking
and you don't care about anything else
c5 of course if you move the knife to a
ridiculous Square Queen h7 is checkmate
so we have to play unites the h5 and now
Carlson plays a very interesting move
but first we should explore a move like
g4g for really an awesome line of course
now you expose your rook to attack but
the idea how black defends is Queen to
d5 going for this Queen captures an e5
check and now after we capture the night
you get Queen e5 check Bishop to e2
blocking and now d3 and now force the
White Queen to capture if you don't want
to get check mated Queen captures you
get Bishop captures on h1 now and after
HK % g 6 you get Queen captures on c3
now force the Queen trade King f1 you
get Queen captures on d3 g captures on
f7 first black pool even capture with
the rook Bishop captures on d3 and now
not capturing the not moving the rook as
you don't want to allow the ship to see
for black just controls this diagonal
Bishop to b5 and here after captures and
captures we get this end game where both
oars have a superandroid but mama D
artists up a poem so and that's with a
perfect attack from white so doesn't
doesn't really work here Carlson
continues with the caveman approach we
have e 6 and here again it's one of
those positions where it's not only okay
to play f6 but f6 is in fact the best
move here but again it's always hard to
decide whether it were to play f6 or not
because everyone has you know bad
memories when they played f6 and then
they lost terribly but your f6 actually
works here white would ignore you Bishop
to d3 you go after g6 and then after
captures you will capture here attacking
the knight then
it looked f6 which is very important as
you always need this rook to h6 threat
after the Bishop captures Bishop
captures and h5 and now Queen to d5 and
you have so many threats this is a
threat this is a threat you can check
King along the e-file and even worship
the f7 is no problem as the dark square
Bishop does a wonderful job of defending
and now there are just so many threats
rook h6 Queen captures here Queen can
deliver checks like we said Queen
captures an 82 and black would just be
much better here
so after each six Mahmud era of mrs. f6
unfortunately for him and Queen to d5 is
played now he wants the harass cross
since King along the e-file with he
captures on f7 Magnus now takes this
opportunity as mama or failed to player
six to grab some material with rook
captures on f7 and now not capturing an
f7 immediately because here this is met
with King captures and you don't have a
good way of continuing your attack
so mama Yara would be very happy to go
this exchange down even something like
Ruby 5 seems like a nice continuation
bishop nicely guards the rook
Queenie core check and after Bishop to
e2 ok you go tonight at 4 attack the
Queen the bishop it's just a very nice
very nice position for black so after
Bishop to d3 we have Queen to e5 check
by Mahmoud Yara it is the strongest move
and now again really exciting where do
we go King to d1 or King to f1 if
cooking to f1 it doesn't work
good night g3 check and well the F pawn
is pinned you cannot capture and you
just fall apart here kingi one you will
go Queen e1 check King h2 you're going
to play King get captures the Queen
captures on h1 and after this straight
here huge you can just go rook c8 again
control the C 4 square you don't wanna
shop c4 and you don't really in mind
this here Knight captures on f7 rook
captures and c3 even as both this bishop
and this this Bishop is guarded but
after Ruby 3 which is best just rook
captures on c1 and after white moves you
will get rooms you wanna check it will
be very hard to keep playing this black
is just winning here so of course Carson
did not go King f1 he went into d1 and
now we have D captures on c3 mama Derek
prefers c2
check as he wants to free this diagonal
for the Queen and the bishop and of
course for the attack that will follow
Carson takes this opportunity to finally
grab the exchanged Knight captures on f7
with King captures on f7 and already
this is move 19 and Colton is down
already
in 19 minutes on the clock so this is
how much he is putting into this game
which is just insane here again what do
you play here you could play something
like Queen III you could offer a queen
trade you could play rugby v go after my
media ups Queen let's say o try Queen
III then you get Queen D 5 and again
black with threats all over the board
rugby 3 defending now you get Bishop to
h6 you try to get the Queen away from
the defense of this Bishop here and
after Queen e2 now you just trade Bishop
captures you will put an in-between move
Ruby 5 as the Queen also now guard the a
to pawn so after C to check you will
capture the bishop and now Knight f4
comes black just has a very very
interesting position and it's well it's
a heart heart to decide on this cross
and instead goes rook to e1 he says the
attack on the King side is over there's
no getting over the dark square bishop
it's time to switch to the center and I
am up material well sort of so why not
mix it up by exchanging Queenston
playing an endgame we see to check by
mama D ro by far the best move like we
said you want open lines in front of
Magnus King Bishop captures and now of
course looked at d8 check bringing your
last rook into the game and only rook
and Bishop to d2 now here you have to
see what happened what's happening here
is Magnus just lost here he has a king
on d1 and mamedyarov has this position
full of attacking potential nice rook
here nice bishop pair queen nicely
centralized well of course you will have
to move it so what do you play here here
at mama D replace Queen to d6 it's very
nice as it guards the e6 square you
don't want to allow this check but also
threatens Queen captures on D -
checkmate
so of course now Magnus has to go Queen
to e3 and now Knight to f4 of course you
cannot capture even though you were
attacking the knight twice the bishop is
still pinned so you just wander your
Queen
we have kinked the c1 by Magnus
unpinning and here do you capture on g2
and attack the Queen and the rook it's a
really nice line that if played this
Magnus would have to find Bishop to b4
and just straight Queens here after
Knight captures Bishop captures you
would have rook captures on d6 and now F
captures on d3 and Magnus would be I'll
be exchanged but mommy tiara of up two
points a nice trade-off but probably
black to be preferred here with the
bishop pair of course
so instead after King to c1 mama D ro
doesn't like his chances here he still
wants a full point as Magnus is getting
really low on time after Bishop h6 you
align your bishop with the Queen and
with the King on this diagonal it's
really looking beautiful and Magnus is
only 7 minutes on the clock here at
shark for 30 minutes so we have King to
be to my Magnus here which is very nice
if you try and prevent 93 by playing
something like group III then Knight the
e2 check is a problem now you have to
capture with the Queen as there is an
open at AK from the worship Queen
captures now Bishop captures and d2 with
check and here black would win back
material visual characters here and
queen capture sunny one again black bees
up up upon and well we could say that
blacks King is a bit safer than whites
King so across and does not go for rugby
3 he goes King to be - trying to get his
King to a much safer Square also now if
the ship g7 is repeated you can respond
with bush of the c3 but it's very
interesting and Mama Daryl did not
repeat even though he might just try and
see if Carson will be interested in a
draw not because mom your wants a draw
but sometimes just you know want to
check how white is feeling but mama drf
continues the attack we've looked the c8
and now Crossan has to decide
Luke c1 or rook 81 Crossing decides for
roof to see one either though even
though rook a d1 probably was a little
bit better as night the d3 will not come
with an attack against the king and the
rook and it also wouldn't work here
night to d3 would actually be very nice
for Mama drf but it forces a lot of
things for example Queen captures you
get Bishop captures on d2 and now you
cannot capture the bishop as your queen
would be unguarded so first you play
rook captures on e7 a nice in-between
move and after
King captures now you capture and rook
81 Brook cd1 traps traps the bishop but
still after Bishop captures you go
capture here with check you get this
position Bishop sort of the same color
mummy are still up upon not interested
in going for this ending Mahmud
iographer wants the wind so he plays
east six he says you're low on time I
just don't want to constantly calculate
Bishop to b3 check it's really annoying
so you play something here across some
place King back to be one now he doesn't
even allow Bishop to g7 to come with
check and now Bishop captures on g2 mama
D are of grabs another pawn and now
comes Bishop to b3 it's a nice idea but
here in well sort of a severe time
trouble Magnus missed Bishop captures on
g6 although although it is better it's
hard to assess with little time on the
clock that it's actually better because
yes you do when the bishop here I mean
it's a trade off but then after Queen d3
trip King b2 Queen d4 check you need to
see that you're okay here and that black
will not be able to finish the job here
you're gonna go roof EC 1 and White's
position is very nice here cross and did
not go for this cross and played Bishop
to b3 places a third attacker towards
the e6 pawn and now comes route captors
and see one immediate goes for some
trades with Bishop captures of course
you don't want to move the rook you want
to keep the pressure along the e file
and out Bishop to h3 my media brings yet
another defender to d6 pawn Bishop to b2
now you want your Bishop on such a
beautiful diagonal and of course
Mammadov doesn't like that so here
before Bishop g7 he goes Bishop f5 check
with King to a one and only now Bishop
to g7
where he is sure that he will be able to
trade these arcs worship switch check so
concentrates first with Bishop captures
King captures and again what do you do
here ruk h1 not all that impressive King
will have a very safe Square on f6 as
you no longer have a dark square Bishop
any Quincy 3 check will be met with
Queen e5 of course after the King goes
to f6 so black is safe here here cousin
goes look 81 route 81 attacks the Queen
and now we have
Knights 2 d 3 and here mom Europe has
some very nasty tricks up his sleeve
he goes unlike queen d8 followed by
Queen f6 check and as the night covers B
- Queen B - will be checkmate for
example if Magnus writes I'm going
Bishop khafre's here with the idea of
trying to remove the defender of the
night here just queen d8 and you are
lost Queen f6 check will will be deadly
you and you cannot block with the Queen
this is covered by the knight and this
is covered by the black queen so we have
Bishop to c4 Carlson in severe time
trouble finds the absolute best move now
threatens to win material here and now
you have to trade Queens a queen e5
check as the knight now controls the e5
square Queen captures on e5 Knight
captures on e5 and now Bishop to e2 and
here we enter the end game where Magnus
says only 30 seconds on the clock and
bamadoro has some three seconds three
minutes and 40 seconds so quite more
time than Magnus but shouldn't be a
problem for Magnus as he is the well
basically the unofficial world champion
in bullets winning all those reaches
titled arenas really must be paying off
I guess in severe time troubles so g4
the bishop is very nicely placed here
controls the night you will know this
famous well relationship between a
bishop in the night and if the King
decides to come into the game you can
always play rook to d4 and cut to the
king wall from the fourth rank but you
know 30 seconds on the clock
Magnus wants to deliver check he can't
hear because of the night of rook c1 he
threatens Roxas c7 check not c8 we have
King to f6 and now rook the c7 disrupted
e3 now we have an option do you want to
keep pieces on the board with the bishop
to d1 but probably due to severe time
trouble Magnus decided it was best not
to overcomplicate the position so we
have Bishop captures on b3 Knight
captures on d3 and now rook captures on
a 7 here Magnus decides it's time for a
race we have Knight captures an f2 ruby
7 going after the b6 pawn g4 mamuro's
starts pushing his past Jeep on and rob6
capturing on me 6 my cousin is not also
ready to start pushing his own passed
pawn
we have g3 now comes a 4 and now a
much-needed move Knight
efore the idea is after the route goes
back to guard the G 1 square you want to
go Knight c3 and attack the roof NDA for
pawn here we have rook to be won by
Magnus but mama Daryl doesn't go for
this double attack instead he goes for
night the c5 he has a different idea how
to play this with a 5 magnets now
doesn't allow the capture and now King
g5 the King now has to join the g2 pawn
if it's ever the geophone if it's ever
to be queen with King to be to buy
Magnus and now King to f4 we have king
to c3 preparing to put the night away g2
and here we have King to c4 Knight to a6
and here King to b5 night the b8 and
even though you would like to push up on
you can't my Medora will just give up
his Knight and bring the King over here
put the pawn and Magnus will have to
trade the rope for a point so that's not
happening
Magnus went back into c4 and now we have
a repetition we have 96 King to be 598
King to c4 Knight to the a6 and here
Magnus even though 30 seconds on the
clock or maybe some 40 seconds I don't
know as it is there's no increment it's
only I don't know how you call it really
I just forgot where you first play the
move and then the time is given back to
you
so not increment but yeah I will
remember it's probably after I make the
video cousin goes root 2 G 1 still tries
to get Mahmud off to make some sort of a
mistake but you know of course it's very
hard to make a mistake here just defend
the past pawn here we have King to d4
rook to f2 and now of course you have to
give up the rook rook captures with King
captors and town team to e5 going after
the pawn here mama Dell defends it and
now what do you play here with a6 just
forcing the knight back and here again
like in the game Alec and Magnus game
with Vishy Anand we have a draw by
insufficient material so there we have a
really an insane game really in the
spirit of mikhail tal really a barbaric
approach but by magnus really wanted to
take my media of down probably I don't
know he probably didn't want to be on
under defending defending side but in
the end it's hard to say I mean even
though it looked like he was on the
defending side it's hard to hard to say
who felt how in this game
as I didn't catch any injury I don't
even know if there was an interview as
they really played this game out for a
very long time but yeah really do hope
you enjoyed it really in the spirit of
Michael Tao I will now show the
standings after round four so for those
who are still not interested in the
standings you know just stop watching or
skip a few seconds here are the
standings a young woman she's still in
sorry not that young a phony she still
is still in first place with three and a
half points full point ahead of Magnus
Carlsen and then we got with two and a
half points crossing and Wesley followed
by a series of two pointers for Bianca
Khurana maxime beaugeois gravely on
Ireland's circuit Cara Kane and then one
and a half pointers Dean Liron onigiri
Sharma media Viswanathan Anand and so
far in last place he Cara Nakamura so it
was not a mommy there was time to take
Magnus down again and the break is
unbeatable streak but you know the
tournament is still young who knows what
can happen
sure that's pretty much it I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Frank
Holmes
Russell wheelhouse and Marco the Rockies
for a conversion to my channel thank you
a lot - really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content continuing this is
olive branches tour are checking
governor of suggestions and if I catch a
breath continuing the Capablanca saga
and once again I apologize for those who
already started watching the video and I
had to take it down
thank you I will see you soon they have
an excellent rest of your day